Renewed concerns about the health of the global economy...
...produced another roller coaster ride in financial markets Friday.
Asian shares took a beating.
Hong Kong's Hang Seng index fell three percent,...
...while Japan's Nikkei lost more than two and a half percent.
The main indexes in Europe extended losses from the previous day,...
...declining more than one percent as the trading day came to a close.
Wall Street added to its losses this week,...
...following warnings from investment bank Morgan Stanley...
...that the United States and the 17 nations that use the Euro may be on the brink of a recession.
Eric Green, Chief Economist at TD Securities, says that the US economy may already be shrinking.
Green says he's not feeling very optimistic.
He blames eroding business and public confidence on the recent political drama in Washington over the US debt...
...and the ineffective response this week by EU leaders on the debt crisis that now threatens Italy and Spain.
What you're seeing is a crisis of confidence here...
...and a crisis of confidence in Europe.
The effects of which are now coalescing into a very rapid slowing in an economy.
I have never seen, in my 20 years of doing this,...
...an economy lose so much momentum so quickly, and that's worrisome.
Prospects for a slowing global economy sent oil prices below 80 dollars a barrel.
Gold hit a new high, Friday, above 1880  dollars an ounce.
An the Dow lost another one and a half percent, Friday, to close at 10,818 points.
Mil Arcega, VOA News.